all right let's discuss some of the
goings on of the last 24 hours as Joe
Biden has continued to not really make a
big deal out of himself one way or the
other but just kind of like be a very
calm presence as president of the United
States doing some things that I like and
then certainly there are things I would
like Joe Biden to do that he has not
done but it's just sort of been very
normal feeling the failed former
president Donald Trump has been doing
interview after appearance after
declaration showing truly how sick he is
at this point in time and the first
example of this that I want to look at
is an interview that Donald Trump gave
yesterday to Newsmax these interviews
are these would make North Korean news
anchors blush these would make Russian
propagandists say oh no that this is
even too much for me
here is a statement Trump is completely
scrambled his brain is completely
scrambled where in the same 50 seconds
he says that he built the wall
but that he would have built the wall if
he had only had three more weeks and
also quite telling that increasingly
Trump is not doing interviews with Fox
News he's doing them with Newsmax and
that's all part of the sort of downfall
of trump and we'll talk more about the
data behind that claim in a moment Mr
President you know another issue that
the Biden Administration is really
completely messed up is the Border it's
just totally messed up guys now what you
have is Governor Ron DeSantis is
taking offensive action he's taking some
of the immigrants and putting them in
Martha's Vineyard
really an incredibly important thing
that DeSantis did I think that the
border is such a disappointment because
we had the safest border we had the best
Border in the history of our country we
built the wall and then I built
additions to the wall which could have
been finished in three weeks I built he
built the wall
now remember the wall was defined as a
wall across the entire border he says we
built the wall
and then we could have finished it
within three weeks wait so did you build
it or did you not the majority of it ah
and everything we said we were going to
get done and then they came to me and
they wanted to know if we could do an
extra 150 to 200 miles yeah they came to
me with tears in their eyes and they
said sir we need another 100 miles no
listen um the promise that Trump made
was a wall across the entire Southern
border by the end of his first term uh
by different accounts something like 90
to 100 and something miles were added
and of course it's a wall that could be
defeated with about a hundred dollars
worth of parts from a Home Depot or a
hardware store Donald Trump then said
that the video of the search warrant
being executed at Mar-A-Lago looks like
a military coup which is interesting
language from the guy who tried to
execute a coup President we keep hearing
about uh video recordings at Mar-A-Lago
that would have captured uh the raid
have you had conversations about
releasing that footage right yes so we
have and they would rather have me not
do it because of the safety of the FBI
agents that swarmed the place right
Trump's really concerned with keeping
the FBI agents safe I don't think they
wanted to swarm it if you want to know
the truth I have a great relationship
with people in the in in the FBI but
they didn't we are very precise and and
you know it's not a pretty picture
either
it looks like uh a military coup
it's not a pretty picture you know if
they didn't want they wanted to uh for
the safety of the people that are on the
footage is very clear and for the safety
of the people that are in the footage
they would they've asked us not to uh
not to put it out you know it's very
interesting that
reality doesn't have any bearing anymore
to the extent that it ever did right
anymore
um when these right Wingers talk about
things in the real world right for a
very long time the January 6th Riot coup
Insurrection attempt call it what you
want
it was peaceful and it was beautiful and
it was a great thing and then all of a
sudden it was well no it was violent but
it was on Tifa and then it was well no
it's a it doesn't really matter it's
just whatever they can say at the time
and now something that was very peaceful
the FBI shows up with a signed search
warrant FBI director signed off on it
attorney general Merritt Garland signed
off on it judge signed off on that now
is a violent military coup and Trump
kind of continued playing this up when
he talked about how violated Melania
felt when the FBI ruffled through her
dresses and maybe other things of hers
as well I I I'm uh wondering how Melania
felt about the raid yeah
by the way a really hard-hitting
question from I believe this is Rick
Grinnell who's like a former Trump
staffer doing the interview I guess he
works for Newsmax now who knows really
incisive Journal how did Melania feel
about what happened
well she felt very violated right this
is a terrible thing
anyway Trump would know about women
feeling violated right two her closet
they go through her dresses and who
knows what else
and uh it wasn't left the way it it her
dresses by the way they didn't go
through her scarves they didn't go
through her blouses
but those dresses they were right up in
there found it okay you know they didn't
exactly I didn't I didn't walk into mine
and say oh this is exactly so nice the
way they put it back
uh I think it's a disgrace that a thing
like this could happen yeah and again we
didn't do anything wrong I didn't do
anything wrong there was nothing done
wrong you take a look at the uh
presidential records act that's where
you have to go by I guess
he's sure he didn't do anything wrong
and maybe it's because of something
related to the presidential records act
remember this this really is a big deal
for the FBI and justice department to
take this step
you know that they were really confident
that they knew exactly what they were
looking for they knew exactly what Trump
was supposed to have turned over and
that they were crossing every eye and
dotting every t as Sean Hannity said
um this this narrative just doesn't it's
not believable I mean that's what I'm
told and you sit you negotiate you try
working it out and if you don't I guess
there's a procedure if you can't work it
out yes and it's you know they're making
they're trying to make such a big deal
because what they want to do is
politicize everything yeah of course it
doesn't appear that that's the case it
appears as though the FBI gave Donald
Trump a lot of time to return the things
that he took and they had reason to
believe he hadn't returned it and they
were 100 correct
um lastly here is uh Trump's still
complaining about the FBI being in his
bedroom you have that happen and then
they do a raid on the house of a former
president who is very popular I mean I
did get more votes than any sitting
president in history no City president
became close it's so it's almost like
he's saying you can't raid a popular
former president you should only be able
to rate an unpopular one and they did a
raid on my house
and it's you know not the same you walk
in and you say these people were in here
and in your bedroom and they were in
embarrassing Melania I mean when you
think how terrible it is it's terrible
it's just absolutely terrible and then
absolute last clip during this very same
deranged and sick interview Trump's
delusions about his own power continue
he says if he were still the president
right now he would meet with Putin and
he would get that invasion of Ukraine
ended Mr President it's Rob finnerty I
don't think it can be overstated
inflation was 1.4 percent on your last
day in office gas was 239 a gallon uh
quite a difference 20 months later uh
speaking of Russia Vladimir Putin wanted
to Showcase Russian strength in Ukraine
when he invaded in February Mr President
the opposite is happening that is clear
if you were in the Oval Office today how
would you do more to us directly with
Vladimir Putin to try to get him to stop
this war
well I talked to him I'd meet with them
I mean there's no communication with him
with Biden takes obviously there's not a
lot of a lot of communication between
Biden and these leaders these leaders
are pretty brutal and they're people
that you have to know how to deal with
and we dealt with them well with China
we took in hundreds of billions of
dollars of tariffs now remember that
China doesn't pay the tariffs American
companies do what's really funny about
that is that when Hillary Clinton said
this really it wasn't a great thing that
Hillary said when Hillary said you know
I went to Wall Street and I told them
cut it out and everybody laughed at her
because it's so silly oh you told Wall
Street to cut it out I'm sure right away
they're going to cut it out Trump's
basically saying the same thing here
he's saying listen I would have met with
Putin I would have told them stop it
just stop it that's it uh it's pathetic
and increasingly Trump's visibility is
coming on Fringe networks like Newsmax
not that Fox News isn't Fringe but it's
at least in terms of cable subscriptions
more mainstream but Trump increasingly
relegated to more bizarre interviews on
smaller and smaller platforms the summer
is over busy season is back in full
force who has time to meal prep and cook
and clean up every single day I don't
and that's why I turn to Splendid spoon
our sponsor Splendid spoon delivers
delicious Ready-to-Eat plant-based meals
right to my door I'm not vegan but I
like increasing my plant intake and
Splendid spoon is the perfect way to do
it so many different reasons why an
increasingly plant-based diet is a great
thing you can choose from over 50 meals
from breakfast smoothies and lunch bowls
to Noodle dinners and light soups so
much variety vegetables legumes health
healthy fats whole grains spices from
all over the world one of my absolute
favorites are the green smoothies so
much great stuff in them get started
today and get a hundred and twenty
dollars off your first three boxes at
splendidspoon.com Pacman the link is
down below